hola que tal el decreto presidencial
consiste específicamente en la creación
de esta comisión de diálogo y
pacificación de los ciertos carcelarios
esto sucede debes recordar que existe un
alto nivel de violencia en los centros
carcelarios del país andino tan solo en
los meses de septiembre y noviembre se
realizó uno de los amotinamientos en los
ciertos carcelarios con niveles
históricos de fallecimientos que
superaron al menos 190 asesinados por el
control de territorio en los centros
carcelarios del país esto obliga dos
ejecutivos nacionales inclusive a
reconocer que no tiene el control total
de los centros carcelarios y a buscar
ayuda internacional específicamente se
crea a través del decreto presidencial
esta comisión de diálogo y pacificación
para buscar una tregua entre los
privados de libertad y el ejecutivo en
nacional también estará desarrollando
trabajo durante los próximos seis meses
ya se ha dicho que en los próximos
quince días deberá ofrecer un informe
pero esta comisión integrada por nueve
especialistas en materia de religión
sistemas carcelarios derechos humanos y
psicología comenzarán inmediatamente
realizar entrevistas en los distintos
centros carcelarios tanto a familiares
como a guías penitenciarios y a privados
es de libertad pero esto sucede como te
he dicho en cuanto a
mis momentos de alta violencia de
motines que se han desarrollado en los
centros carcelarios también se ha
realizado una visita de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos una
delegación que visitó el país para
verificar los centros carcelarios pero
no pudo ingresar a los centros
carcelarios pacíficamente por motivos de
seguridad de igual forma el presidente
de la república ha dicho una vez más que
en este intento él está comprometido por
fortalecer el sistema de rehabilitación
social y sucede básicamente cuando se
han producido fuertes declaraciones por
parte del embajador de los estados
unidos
'ecuador michael fitzpatrick donde él
señala que hay
penetración del narcotráfico inclusive
en los cuerpos del orden lo que ha
exigido la respuesta por parte del
ejecutivo nacional a dar detalle a los
eeuu en lo que sucede en este momento
con el sistema carcelario